日本のとある場所に
史上最強と言われるファイターが住んでいた。
彼は、人体模型戦では
負けなし。
ボクシング界では
織田信長と、呼ばれていた。
「ｳｯｽ」
「ﾌｰｯ」
「ｱｯ」
「こんにちは」
「プロ・・・
プル・・ﾌﾟﾛｯ・・・」
「バトル田中だ。」
「まあ、みんな、緊張しないでくれ。」
「おれは優しい男だ。」
「ｼｭｯ」
「新たなボクシングのトレーニングを開発しようと思って、
今日は動画を撮っている。」
「ｼｭｼｭｯ」
「一般的にボクシングのトレーニングは
パンチが基本になる。」
「ｼｭｼｭｼｭｼｭｯ」
「まあ、普通はこういうやつを使うわけだ。」
「サンドバッグ」
「TE○GAではない。」
「ボクシングの練習では
ここでサンドバッグに向かって
パンチの打ち込みをするのが基本。」
「いま見てもらって、分かったと思うんだが、
パンチをすると戻ってこなくなる時がある。」
「こういう感じにね。」
「いくら、サンドバッグといえど、
おれのパンチによって、倒れている事実は変わりない。」
「倒れるサンドバッグを攻撃してても、
ダメだ。」
「結局おれはこの勝負に勝っているっていう意味だからな。」
「サンドバッグは倒れている。」
「俺は立っている。」
ﾊﾟﾝｯ
「おれの勝ちだろ？」
「ｼｭｼｭｼｭｼｭｯ」
「というわけで、今日は、
「サンドバッグが倒れるようならば、
倒れないサンドバッグを作ったら、どうだろだろうか？」
「ﾌｨｷｼ」
「おれは思ったわけよ。」
「ｼｭ」
「倒れないサンドバッグを作りたいと。」
「ｼｭ」 ﾊﾞﾀﾝ
「ｼｭｼｭｼｭｯ」
「なので、今回はちょっと大量のサンドバッグを準備したので
「ｼｭ」
サンドバッグをこれからたくさんくっつけていきます。」
「サンドバッグがたくさんつけれれば、ひょっとしたら、
ﾊﾟﾝｯ
「おれのパンチを喰らっても
倒れないサンドバッグができるんじゃねーか。」
「そうすると、俺よりも強いサンドバッグ・・・」
「燃えるゼ。」
「倒れない!」
「最強のサンドバッグを作ろうと思います。」
「ｼｭｯ」
「これまず倒れるんですよね。攻撃すると。」
「倒れないサンドバックを作ってみようと思います。」
「では行こう!」
「やばっ!!」
「部屋に収まりきらんばかりの、サンドバックを準備した。」
「ここからは、サンドバックをくっつけてって、
徐々にサンドバックを大きくしていって、
俺のパンチでサンドバックが床に着いた瞬間、俺の勝ち。」
「床につかないサンドバックができたら、
それが最強のサンドバックです。」
「では、くっつけていきましょう！」
「まずは、3つだ。」
ﾊﾞﾘﾊﾞﾘｯ
ﾌﾟｷﾞｬｰ
ﾊﾞｧﾊﾞｧﾊﾞｧ
「こんな感じで、どうだ。」
ﾊﾟﾝｯ
「まずは、サンドバッグ3個だぁ。」
らーうんどわーん「ﾖﾛｼｬｽ!! ｵﾅｼｬｽ!!」
「ﾌｰｯ」
ﾊﾞﾝｯ
「ｵｯ」
ﾊﾞｯﾀﾝ
ﾋﾟｭ~
ﾋﾟｮﾝ
ﾀﾝｯ
ﾄﾞｶﾞｯ
「ｲﾔｯｽ!!」
「ｲﾔｯｽ。」
「次は、6本、6本でいきましょう」
「できたぞ」
「サンドバッグ6本との勝負だ」
「お願いします」
「えっ、まじか」
「っしゃー！」
「ちょっと次はもう今あるの全部くっつけて
「最強状態にします」
「できました」
「これが俺の最後の相手です」
「この俺のボクシング人生
約30分」
「20年間の集大成です」
「絶対倒します」
「かかってこいや」
「さあいよいよやってまいりました」
「バトル田中選手ファイナルラウンドです」
「気合が入っているようですね」
「さあ、敵とはかなり体重差がありますが
どのようにして戦うのでしょうか」
「さあ試合が始まりました」
「実況、私はじめしゃちょーがお送りします」
「よろしくお願いします」
「おっ、いきなりパンチをかますが
ビクともしない」
「全く通じていないようですね」
「これは完全にボディが強い」
「仕上がっている」
「バックドローップ！」
「あーっ、だがしかしカウンターが入る」
「おーっとバトル田中選手これは苦しいようです」
「立てない！」
「大丈夫か」
「これはかなり効いているようですね」
「そうですね」
「おっ、しかし立った」
「おっ、まだいけるようですね」
「さあ、確実にパンチを決めていく」
「最強だ」
「お前が一番つえーよ」
「お前が最強のファイターだ」
「だが、俺もこんなところで負けていられねえ」
「くらえ！」
「ジャンピングダッ」
「空気抜くか・・・」